certicom un joyau au coeur de la cité
notre dame de paris dont l'évêque
maurice de sully posa la première pierre
en 163 possédait un trésor qui
rassemblait des objets précieux les plus
divers du à la générosité des évêques
des rois les princes et du peuple
chrétien le 12 août
1756 la première pierre d'un nouvel
édifice fut posée par le chanoine
guillot de montjoie que l'on voit ici
peint par duplissy tenant le plan du
souffle aux cet édifice devait abriter
les richesses accumulées malgré les
ventes du chapitre et les envois la
fonte exigé par le roi en 1830 et 1831
le trésor fut pillée et dévasté des
objets précieux jetés à la seine
l'oeuvre de soufflot incendié dû être
démoli un concours fut ouvert en 1843
pour la restauration de la cathédrale
deux architectes l'astuce et viollet le
duc l'emportèrent en 1844
ils commencèrent la construction de la
sacristie sur le côté sud du coeur
le 15 avril 1854 le bâtiment fut bénie
par monseigneur ciboure la grande salle
dite du trésor à de grandes verrières du
à maréchal de m elle représente
plusieurs évêques de paris
les meubles ont été dessinés par viollet
le duc notamment cette grande armoire
qui s'inspire d'un meuble du musée de
cluny et renferme les pièces antérieures
à la révolution
intérieurement des ventes au point par
perraudin évoque la vie de saint louis
avec sa mère blanche de castille son
amour pour les peaux son départ pour la
terre sainte et sa mort
ce qu'alice en vermeil du 16e siècle est
décoré d'armoiries émaillé dans les
niches se voit de ce un personnage
ces deux amphores également du 16e
siècle sont en vermeil décoré de
filigranes d'argent travail d'augsbourg
c'était glières et son bassin en argent
sont du xviie siècle sur la panse de la
guerre une scène représente le baptême
du christ
ces statuettes sont des reliquaires du
début du xviiie siècle
elle proviendrait de la suisse voici
saint-roch sainte barbe
saint sébastien et sainte agathe
ce qu'alice russe du xviiie siècle s amp
athènes selon le rite orthodoxe
du grands sculpteurs françois girardon
ce pur chef-d'oeuvre est exceptionnel
par la qualité de sa composition et la
beauté des sculptures ce serait à don de
louis xiv à une personne de son
entourage
peut-être la très pieuse madame de
maintenon
mais le trésor de notre dame est
essentiellement à trésors du 19e siècle
napoléon 1er aux frites en 1804 ce
merveilleux reliquaire dorment ou lui
destiné à la couronne d'épinés et
exécuté dans un style néo classique par
l'orfèvre cahiers on y remarque le lion
de juda coucher au pied de la fois trois
anges soutiennent le blob on retrouve
sur le socle la couronne d'épinés
napoléon iii offre à son tour un
somptueux reliquaire toujours pour la
sainte couronne de style néogothique
dessiné par viollet le duc qui s'inspira
de l'art mosan ce chef-d'oeuvre fut
réalisée par leur faivre poussière
gruson les statuettes assises
représentent sainte hélène
saint louis
et baudoin deux empereurs de
constantinople
elles sont deux jours froids de chaume
la couronne de fleurs de lys est en
vermeil enrichi de pierreries
au colonel des arcatures sont adossés
les douze apôtres
voici un autre très beau reliquaire dit
de saint-claude dessinait aussi par
viollet-le-duc il se distingue par
l'harmonie de sa composition qui fait
alterner le vermeil et l'argent se
portent custode a été ciselée en 1814
par l'orfèvre louis louga au sommet
l'agneau repose sur le livre ou sept
saulx offert par les chevaliers du saint
sépulcre en 1823 ce calice et sap
athènes sont en vermeil le calice et
ornée de trois gros améthyste et d'une
croix de jérusalem surmontée d'une
couronne
le 1er novembre 1823 monsieur frère du
roi le futur charles 10 offrait à
l'église sainte genevière cet ensemble
oeuvre de l'orfèvre cahier composé d'un
plateau d'un calice d'une pâte n
l'origine princière se lit à l'intérieur
du pied du calice
trois médaillons en porcelaine de sèvres
représentent des scènes de la passion
l'agonie le portement de croix le
crucifiement sur le noeud du calice les
médailles on montre le christ la vierge
et ça j'en
sur la fausse couche
la foi l'espérance et la charité
sur la patène on peut voir les pèlerins
d'emmaüs l on retrouve sur le pied les
évangélistes dans des médaillons un ange
et les formes lance de la bure est sur
la pente l'histoire de noé évoque le vin
du sacrifice le miracle de moïse faisant
jaillir l'eau du rocher était sur
l'autre buret voler en 1944 oeuvre de
l'orfèvre audio
cette vierge d'argent a été offerte elle
aussi au trésor par le roi charles vi le
15 août 1826 cette chapelle fut donné
par napoléon iii aux chanoines de places
qui prêcha aux tuileries le carême en
c'est un délicat travail de vermeil et
des mouches enlever des scènes
évangélique décor les quatre lob du pied
qui sont séparés par quatre dragons
descendant de la tige au centre de
celle-ci le ne comporte quatre médaillon
représentant les symboles des quatre
évangélistes
vous voyez le lion de saint marc c'est
l'orfèvre poussière gruson qui exécuta
toujours sur les desseins de viollet le
duc
le reliquaire du cloud et du bois de la
croix il est en argent garni de diamant
de perles
et de pierres précieuses deux anges aux
ailes déployées soutiennent la croix
latines ou sans chasse la parcelle de la
vraie croix l'ostensoir de sainte
geneviève a été aussi exécuté par
poussière sur un dessin de constant du
feu
toujours de poussière gruson ce qu'alice
à des médaillons en mosaïque
le trésor de notre dame est un trésor
vivant il continue de s'enrichir au 20e
siècle
c'est ainsi que nous pouvons admirer la
couronne de la vierge de charles 10 elle
a été exécutée en 1925 par le grand
joaillier boucheron
elle a été réalisée avec des diamants
des perles et du lapis lazuli provenant
des bijoux d'une généreuse donatrice
ce christ du xviie siècle des rubis
incrusté dans l'ivoire symbolise les
gouttes de sang d'où son nom le christ
au rugby il fut offert par le cardinal
amette en 1917 l'ostensoir de chez ray a
été offert par les orfèvres parisien en
1949 pour le cinquième centenaire de la
tradition du mai 714 249 que la
corporation des orfèvres décida d'offrir
chaque année à la vierge le 1er mai un
arbre feuillu des corps et appelés lemay
revêtus de catamarans les orfèvres
parisiens se rendent chaque année en
procession à notre dame pour offrir
l'arbre vert à la vierge
en 1949 également fut offerte par le
mexique en souvenir du pèlerinage
célèbres de notre dame de guadalupe
comparable à lourdes
cette couronne en or garnis des toiles
de diamant de perles émeraudes
on la voit ici couronnant la vierge sur
son tableau en mosaïque
l'empereur haïlé sélassié importe à
cette croix lors de sa visite officielle
à paris en 1954
c'est le pape jean xxiii qui offrit en
1961 ceux-ci boire en souvenir de sa
lancia tueur
il légua en 1963 ce bocaly ce qui lui
avait été donné par le gouvernement
italien
lors de sa visite à lorette est assise
offerte au trésor ces deux esquisses
razer religieuse du grand sculpteur
carpeaux dégage une intense émotion mais
pour les chrétiens le plus grand attrait
du trésor de notre dame sont ces
reliques voici pieusement conservé la
tunique de saint-louis accompagnée d'un
texte en français du 15e siècle son
discours jette ou discipline instruments
de pénitence du roi chevalier
ce reliquaire exécuté par famechon en
1828 contient une des plus importantes
reliques de la vraie croix visible
revers 7 reliques ainsi que la plaque en
or à double traverse appartenait à un
âne de clèves princesse palatine
d'où son nom de croix palatine
la princesse la lega à l'abbaye de saint
germain des prés en souvenir de son beau
frère jean casimir roi de pologne qui la
lui avait remise quand il se réfugie en
france à la cour de louis xiv
une inscription en grec indique que la
relique appartint à manuel comme neil
empereur de byzance morts 11 181 en bas
du reliquaire un clou de la passion
légué aussi par la princesse palatine
mais plus que tout autre relique la
sainte couronne d'épinés fait de gens
entre l'as et forcent le respect
saint-louis l'a reçu en 12 138 de
l'empereur de constantinople beaudoin 2
elle arriva à paris le 19 août 12 139
escorté d'un splendide cortège en tête
duquel marsh est louis 9 et son frère le
compte des retours après une halte à
notre dame la chasse fut déposée dans la
chapelle du palais en attendant la fin
de la construction de la sainte chapelle
en 248
pendant les troubles en 1791 la sainte
couronne fut transféré à saint denis
puis à l'hôtel des monnaies ensuite
confiée au cabinet des médailles où elle
resta dans un tiroir jusqu'en 1804 le
cardinal de belloy demande à la remise
de la sainte couronne un procès verbal
de vérification reconnu son authenticité
le 6 août 1806 c'est alors que napoléon
1er offrit le bo reliquaire est que le
10 août 1806 la vénérable reliques fut
déposée en grande pompe aux trésors de
notre dame que depuis lors elle n'a plus
quitté
paul claudel a écrit jadis à l'époque
qui a précédé ma conversion ou faute de
pouvoir communier jallet vénérer les
reliques d'un signe de la passion la
sainte couronne le clou et le morceau de
la croix avec l émotion j'ai appliqué
mais l'ère du profond trésors de notre
dame
elles sont l'élément inestimable